So the issue is
whereas
he said that
should be But I might
>> tell them to you down.
>> I wasn't here for I wasn't here for
that. So
>> this is why and I'm saying that
and specifically asking you know
any question you're not asking them for
whatever benefit you want.
of you know
being you know protected from you know
asking them asking them to make dua to
Allah for you
>> just like and and and and you know us
who you know accept
we don't um we don't distinguish between
asking a live person to make love for
you
>> and asking a dead person to There's one
because the the the determinant in
asking or rather the determinant that
leads you to ask the live person and the
real person to make dua for you is not
necessarily the you know the the hay or
the it's the ability the ability that's
essential it's like you know the the
reason what makes the reason that leads
me to ask you for anyone to make to make
dua is because I believe that you can
>> um make dua for me.
>> Okay. And the same reason that would
lead me to make uh to ask a dead person
to make dua for me is because I believe
that that person uh can make dua for me.
So if you allow me to finish now
>> your ability to make dua for me is it
from your own that like is it is it from
your own capability or is from the Allah
that Allahh enabled you to make that you
able to right because you know you're
alive right if my question is if
you know life if being alive is the only
determinance that you
Then you know a sick person someone
who's in the com is alive right or
someone who's crazy they're alive or you
know a you know a child who you know a
2-year-old they're alive right but can
they can they make dua like so the
ability
>> so so the ability is not just determined
by the you know the being alive or being
dead It's it takes more than that. Now
the dead person
yes they dead
right but
Allah says
>> right so
right and and the ones who do we believe
that the same way that I would ask you
to make for me I'm I'm not dependent on
your ability and dependent on the
to enable you to make. So the same with
the same concept the same is that if I
ask a person to make dua for me I'm not
dependent on the ability of that new
person I'm dependent on the that Allah
subhana tala
the same Allah subhana wa ta'ala who
enabled you you know to make dua for me
is the same Allah Allah subhana tala who
will enable
Yeah.
>> Oh,
>> and this is this is the
>> All right.
What what has made you conclude that
Allah has given any of the dead
permissions?
>> So the question here is not whether
um it's not whether
it's not whether it's it's about does is
Allah able or not.
>> Yeah. Allah is able right? Look, we're
not talking about ability, Allah's
ability. We know Allah is able. But when
you establish that as a premise, on what
basis are you establishing and affirming
that Allahel has given them the given
the dead the ability to make that dua on
behalf of anyone in the room,
>> the fact that he's able to give the
>> he's able to, but we need some
affirmation.
What has by way of what thing are we
otherwise the the argument is is a
non-starter
you mentioned
those can we can we would we be able to
call upon them
>> and ask them
>> to ask them to Yeah.
>> To do the good for you or to make dua to
>> make dua.
>> Yes,
>> you can.
>> Based on what?
>> Because they able to do rather we
believe that they're able to do Allah
enables them to do.
>> Why? Because they're alive.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And that life that life is it life
that has and and a consideration as far
as we are concerned?
>> I'll tell you why it isn't.
When the shahid or when the shahid
passes away, do you mean
>> what happens when we
get he gets inherited?
>> It gets inherited. Why?
>> Because Allah
because Allahh
you know that's not the jaw that you you
should be given.
It gets inherited. Why? Why is wealth
inherited by anyone? How?
>> Because he can't like physically.
>> But what's the cause of inheritance?
>> Death.
>> So the shahid when he passes away his
wealth is inherited.
>> Okay. So with him passing away
uh what happens with his wife? uh he
she's she gets into
>> and after she can get married
>> she can get married and it happened many
times
we understand therefore that that
is
it is a life that exists in the is not
life that has for me and you that's
number one if it is and as far as we are
concerned learned
his life has ended though he's alive his
life has ended then number one his
consider the our consideration of what
allahel has mentioned that they are
alive in the banza as far as that which
relates to us is passed away made it
mean and if that wasn't the case then
all of his wealth wouldn't be the
divided ed he wouldn't have there would
be no inheritance his wife wouldn't be
able to marry why because he's alive
uh so returning back to the question on
what basis are we saying it is
permissible to make dua to him in order
for allahel or that his dua will be uh
or our dua to him will be answered and
that he will ask uh of Allah on behalf
of us we have to have some evidence.
So the fact that he can hear and the
fact that Allah can enable him to do so
and to us it's like these these two are
the only criteria
>> and also you know that if we we we look
at which is
>> right when I do I am doing it I'm not
trying to convince anyone to do it right
>> right
>> so if someone comes
>> so when you do it no no but when could
do it. You must do it for some basis.
You can't just do it just based upon
feeling
>> based on the fact that the dead person
can hear and can do it.
>> But the dead person number one, the dead
person that is not something that is
affirmed
that all dead people can hear. Our
belief is that the dead hear what
Allahel or his messenger have permitted
them to hear what we have textual
evidence for. Number one. Number two, if
it were the case the prophet can hear.
Do you mean and that and that he can
conversate with allahel
and that that's something that goes on
and he's in in knowledge upon knowledge
of what has taken place after his death
and after he's left the dunya
answer me in relation to the hadith uh
of the prophetam said
and that a people will be brought before
me and I would there yeah I would say
ashabi asabi
They will be taken away from me. What is
it? The prophet mentioned will be said,
"Verily, you do not know what they have
brought about after you." The same
messenger that we say is alive and can
still hear and still understands and
knows and is familiar with what is
taking place. He as the prophetam here
he said about himself that it will be
said to me you do not know what has been
brought to you uh what what they brought
about after you during his lifetime the
prophetam there occurred affairs among
the with the and the hypocrites the
prophet wasallam didn't know about them
while he was alive
from the people of the of You do not
know them.
We know them. Allahel mention to the
prophetam. Likewise, what did allahel
mention?
Say to them,
if I knew the unseen, then no harm would
have touched me and I would have been
abundant upon.
So here we have an affirmation of
prophetam not knowing while he was alive
the unseen not knowing that which
occurred in his presence while he was
alive
when he went on uh to the we likewise
have an affirmation of the fact that the
prophetam did not know of the things
that occurred in and among his um
because he will be informed of them he
will be informed of them when those
individuals are removed from his house
Okay, why don't we have a companion from
among the companions of the messenger
who would go to the grave of the prophet
and ask him make dua to him. You have
one narration from any of them.
[Music]
>> Was he alive or was he dead? He he did
tell us with alive or was he dead?
>> The prophet was dead.
>> Was he
abbas and were the two of them alive or
was Abbas dead?
>> Both of them were alive. But
>> but the wasn't ambassador of it was his
relationship with the prophet
>> he said
>> even if that is the case even if that is
the case what what is the what is the
evidence in that there isn't any
evidence in other
father
in the Wasallam
a noble righteous upright companion of
the messenger of of the messenger
wasallam related to the prophetam but he
was alive
why didn't
say that allahel has maintained his
messenger alive in his grave let us go
to the grave of the messenger of Allah
bypass abbas who is alive prophetam is
alive in his grave let us go to the
grave of the messenger
let us ask the prophetam
Just because um
do you know the the
You can't find from the ocean.
>> Who is better? Who is better?
Ambassador's
alive in his grave according to you
listening to the duas of the people. Why
didn't
go to go to the grave of the messenger
and ask the prophet sallall alaihi
wasallam instead of Abbas? Because Abbas
the needed the water
and his relationship.
>> Stop relationship.
>> Stop stop.
>> If Abbas need if it was Abbas that
needed the water why why is even in the
narration approach Abbas.
>> Okay. So
when this didn't need water when he
drinks when he drinks does it only
benefit or everyone
right now we're not dealing with who
benefits we're dealing with why did go
to Abbas
why did not go to the grave of the
prophetam and ask the prophetam in his
grave
>> he took one of the was he could have he
could have gone directly to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
Right.
>> Could have you could have gone to
>> you could have but you bypassed the
father.
>> Okay. If you if you pray at home and you
don't pray at the mid
>> right
>> is it because praying at home is better
than masid or it's allowed to pray at
home too.
>> No but this is not an issue here. This
is a completely different issue. Salah
at home salah and both of those things
are established
>> textually. You know what I mean?
>> Here we have an issue. We are arguing
that one of them is established.
>> Right? You're trying to make a case for
what is not established and what enters
into
for you to make that case. You cannot
make it on and
it must be something established
evidence that is established and at the
at the very least some of the companions
must have done it.
of he mentions.
He said, "Look, may Allah show you mercy
to the position or the statement of
anyone you hear speaking in your time.
Don't be hasty and do not enter into
anything from it until you first ask is
it something that the messenger of Allah
wasallam said last one that the
companions of the messenger Allah said
or any of the
if you find the narration then cling to
it. Don't go past it for anything. don't
choose anything over it and thus fall
into the fire.
And so the question here is do we have
an e from any of the companions of the
messenger that they did what you're
suggesting
>> the just mentioned
>> that's not a
>> okay let me ask
>> then it's not in the mis
>> it doesn't it doesn't revolve around why
because making with the dua of the
righteous with the dua of the nobody
disagrees with this that is not the
issue the issue is making dua um and
making using the the dead for
and you will not I will answer it for
you. You will not find a narration your
issue is you will not find a narration
from any of the companions of the
messenger.
You will not find a narration from any
of the You will not find a narration
from any of the
the four imams. You won't find anything
from any one of them. Not Abu Hanifh,
not imm.
So the is
where you getting it from? Number one.
Number two, why do you feel you need it?
here the scholar they mentioned a
beautiful point about this ayah
prophetam
when Allah ordinarily when the prophetam
conveys
from allahel Allah will say in many
instances
uh
say to
here. The prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Allahel mentioned.
If my servants ask about me then indeed
I am closed. Allahel did not say
mentioned that has a clear indication.
The reason for that is that allahel wish
to establish that when it comes to the
dua of the servants of Allah to allahel
there is no need for any from among the
creation not the prophet wasallam or
anyone else. And so here Allah did not
even mention or say say to them that I
don't need you as a mediator to inform
them if my servants ask me then indeed I
am closed. What is it that the
Christians and the Jews and and
up to the time of what did they fall
into? this very thing that you're
advocating why do you feel you need it
is the issue allahel has given us this
ayah I am close allahawel mentioned
allah allahel loves that the servant
calls upon him and if he leaves asking
Allah
is an authentic allahel is angry with
him
and and allahel mentions
[Music]
I am the one who least least need of any
partner. Allah is no mediator and we
need no mediator to bring our dua to
Allah. So why is it even an issue for
you? Why are you burdening yourself with
this when the when the the and the
people of knowledge throughout the
throughout the centuries have returned
to Allah with their dua with the
supplication that has in it
and what your the path that you're
traversing is the path
of the
what was it that they said the
statements that they made that
that we don't worship them. We just want
them. We just need always this issue of
me having a mediator or needing a
mediator was a problem.
My advice to you uh
my brother Mktar my advice to you is
leave alone the path because it's not
necessary
if in it is in it is overburdening
yourself and you're walking a very
dangerous path by walking this path a
very dangerous path that is the path of
the mush of the past let not let them
not be who you inherited from the path
of the was clear is easy it is straight
forward. Worship Allahawel.
Turn to allahel in dua. Supplicate to
allahel. Ask him to forgive you your
sins. Whatever it is you're asking for,
turn to allahel directly. You don't need
a mediator. Not the messenger of Allah
or anyone other than the messenger.
Alhamdulillah is one that is easy. And
as allahel mentions those who are called
upon
they those they
themselves seek with Allah
they themselves seek nearness to Allah
whether it is wheam whether it is the
people of righteousness we have no need
for them
I may never see you again.
Leave it alone. Abandon it. There's no
good for you and you don't need it.
We're not Christians.
Muslim.
That's all we need.
>> We're done.
>> Okay. So, you mentioned quite a list of
ayat and you know, I hope you have the
time. I hope everyone has the time for I
respond to every single one of them.
We don't need any response to them.
>> We don't need any response to them.
>> Let me let me explain something to you.
>> The believer in revolves around what is
known as anyone.
There is
that no one other than Allah is
subjugated to there is that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam we do not
make dua to him. There is
>> no there is no there is I mean there is
no dua to him and not through him
there's a difference
>> to him but through him upon the most
correct state like that but go on
>> there is the prophetam he himself said
what's the meaning
>> don't give me is just a mass of the of
the man what he said.
>> I don't know.
>> No, I'm asking you.
>> I don't know. Like
>> No, but you've just you went into some.
So what do you understand from that
statement?
>> Okay. I
>> So I I acknowledge this one nurse that
you mentioned.
>> You tell me.
>> No, I don't I don't want to know if you
acknowledged it. I want to know you
understand what it means.
>> Okay, I understand.
>> Prophetam said, "Do not take my grave as
an Eid." An Eid is a place that one
constantly returns back to comes back
to. Why would the prophetam make that
statement if it was legislated for his
ummah to supplicate to him to make dua
to him and to approach him? Why would he
make that statement?
This is the moment of the west. It's the
the
difference between
and asking to make dua. These are two
different things, right? You when I want
to do with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, there's no And there's no
necessity that I have to travel all the
way to Medina. I can
>> true. But why? But why? If the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
legislated,
why? Certainly if it is legislated, if
it is legislated, it is a good thing.
Number one, anything that is legislated,
then it's
if it is from why would the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam say
Do not take my grave as a place that you
constantly return back to.
>> Why
you tell I don't know.
>> No, but you're supposed to be
establishing this as a worship and
something that is good and something
that draws you closer to Allah. Why
would the prophetam say
but I give a different
when he was on his deathbed
He says
rewind in another version
and the other hadith I mentioned earlier
If
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was legislating, why would the prophetam
say do not take my my grave as a masjid,
a place of salah? Why would the
prophetam say do not take my masid uh my
my grave as a place that you repeatedly
return back to?
Don't do it. Prior to that statement, he
said, "May Allah curse
the
curse.
Curse
distancing from the mercy of Allah." So
the prophetam said, "May they be distant
from the mercy of Allah for taking the
graves of them of the Amyia as places of
of prayer."
Do not do that with me.
Please enlighten me. Why would the
prophetam make that statement if this
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was mash was legislating and
something we should be doing?
I can respond now.
So it's one of two things right? It's
either the points you brought up
and three things.
and these are three things. So it's one
of two things. It's either
is equal to
or
>> No, I'm asking you cuz you're the one
who
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. But
you're the one that suggested it's so
I said one or two
you said
>> this is one of the this is the first
option I was getting to the second
>> no
>> what is
using the same ideas to to give two
things the same
Yes.
Something that we don't have a ruling
with upon with an something that we do
have a ruling upon because of anah
because of a a a common shared
right reason. So when you're saying it's
either
I'm asking you because for it to be kas
there must be a and an
we make kas of this upon that. So what
came to your mind when you said that it
is
it's either kas of what upon what?
>> So maybe maybe the way it sounded cuz I
was asking you so you cuz you mentioned
You mentioned
[Music]
and then you mentioned
>> So my question to you,
>> are they the same thing?
>> Yeah.
>> Or they related?
>> They're related. What is the proof that
is most definitely related to um
what is the relationship?
>> What is the relationship between the
relationship is
>> okay?
So is count.
Yes.
All right. If I say I'm going to worship
uh uh this bottle, I've now made this
bottle a shik with Allah.
If I was because is with righteous deeds
to is with righteous actually with or
with the the names and the attributes of
Allahel with the dua of the righteous.
You mean the dua of the righteous is
that we make we seek dua from them for a
particular thing. Dua with the righteous
actions is that we say oh Allah this
action I performed it for your sake.
You mean if I did it for your sake and
it was sincerely for you then help me
and aid me with touch and touch that is
those are two types of if we put the
with the names of allahel aside because
it doesn't have this particular relation
so a man who says I'm going to make with
now instead of
or or our seeking the father from
allahel. we seek the father.
>> So,
>> okay.
>> That's
>> If I if if if the one who's asking me
has I am the one who owns
>> the
definition
to your question.
>> No, the is the form of no. Let me ask
you explain to me your your thoughts how
it okay for how it manifests. Let me
understand this
>> um according to us right we don't
distinguish
>> hold sorry who is us
>> you like your names or
>> no what what is it is it school is
>> I mean we we call ourselves
but you know that's that's debatable
Because you know if you consider us
>> who founded this
>> it's it's filling from now to the and
from the time of the prophet
and it's
>> all the way through
>> all the way. Yes.
>> So why don't you have anything from the
companions?
>> I was about to mention like now are you
going to give me the chance?
>> No, I will give you the chance. what
you're saying Gil and that should have
gone way all the way back to the
>> so I'm saying then who are we who don't
agree with what you're saying
>> that's the thing so we're here to
determine who's who's act
with you right now who are we
>> okay so when I say we don't consider you
know um whoever is not us
being not and we don't
>> it's Like we we acknowledge that
although we have you know the the the
differences of opinion on on many
matters.
>> Okay. And which are you following?
Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So are you going to let me uh
>> Hold on. Okay. So whenever I um I asked
you to to make dua for me,
you're able to make dua for me, right?
And your height and your
[Music]
>> are these three the only determinants
>> generally with the people of no.
Thank you.
>> Now my question to you is before you
make that statement Yeah.
All right. Continue.
>> Okay. When
right when the the blind person came to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah.
>> And he asked me he asked him you know
make dua for me to to cure me.
>> What did the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tell him? He told me
>> what did he do?
>> He he told me go make
>> udu
>> then
>> go pray
>> and then make to Allah.
>> Okay then. And then what is the dua?
>> He said he said Allah and what did he
say? He himself said
he himself.
[Music]
Okay. So this is the
Okay.
>> Not that's not that's not the
[Music]
So what's the point of saying this part?
Muhammad
at Muhammad kind of went.
>> Where was Muhammad?
>> It wasn't
the prophetam told him what go.
>> Ah, so he just went this way. That was
it.
>> He went,
>> he went and come back.
He went to come back and prophet taught
him the dua
in front of him. Then he said
that's missing and I'm looking for
you. You're finally
>> the point is
uh the effect of
other than allahel
is from the that you have no need for
I don't know why you're doing this. This
is clearly in defense
of of a of a of a mab and a but perhaps
you were nurtured upon it and so
defending what you were nurtured upon
and you feel the necessity of defending
the position of your forefathers or
something of that nature. That may well
be the case. But then I want to remind
you of the statement of
We found our forefathers upon the way
and we are just following their way.
Don't be that individual.
>> You following me?
>> No.
>> Don't be that guy.
>> Don't be that guy. Be the one that
returns and seeks knowledge sincerely
for the sake of allahel. turns to Allah
recognizes that we don't need these.
Why would you follow this? Why
do you feel like Allahel is not going to
answer your dua without this?
Is Allah not able to answer your dua
without this?
If you you affirm and I know you know
and you know allahel so why are you why
are you doing acrobatics
to try and affirm this
turn to allahel
without any mediator without any need we
don't need any mediator as much as we
love the messenger the prophetam is not
a mediator between us and Allah when it
comes to dua and worship and
supplication we don't need
So my advice to you is
it is it's a path that will only lead to
if you haven't already fallen into
how old you are.
>> 28 mktar.
>> So you you 28 m. Why you feel you need
this this?
>> You don't need
>> So why you doing it for them?
>> Just because you don't need something
doesn't mean you can't do it.
>> Come on. What can I follow?
>> Okay.
Just because you can't just because you
don't need it don't mean
>> Yeah. It's
>> Is this is it?
>> Why are you going to waste your time
with something that is
the prophet trees rewired?
So this is the one who brings about
the one who acts upon something that's
not from our affair.
[Music]
Whoever brings about in this affair that
which is not in it
that there's no text for this thing in
our dean. What we understand from that
is our action our our belief our our
must be in the religion. Yeah. The
source of the action is in the religion.
I mean, we've established and you know
it as well. You know it as well that we
can't affirm what you're saying. You
can't affirm it. You can't affirm it
from the hadith of the messenger. You
can't affirm it from the statement of
the companion or action of the
companions
as many of the invention.
If it was something that was good, the
man would have preceded us to it.
Companion. Anybody better than the
companions in action and deed and and
and
who
is better than the
>> What's about the
>> necessity that just because they didn't
do something that we're doing now
>> means that we claim to be better than
this that it doesn't I mean it doesn't
stand.
>> All right. All right. And I I can give
you
>> saying you said yes.
>> I'll give you what the prophetam said
and you tell me.
>> Sorry.
>> I'll give you what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam tell. You
tell me right.
The best of the people is my generation.
Then those who follow them then those
who follow them. Best how
>> best in in
carpentry and and and mechanics
>> there's many criteria
>> best how what in your understanding best
how
>> just the fact that
>> best when said best what is he referring
>> but what what what what criteria what
characteristics is he referring to that
they possess is the best
in terms of their
>> the best
>> of the people is there in the large
country that the best. So
that's a statement to the prophet
>> that is in line with the statement that
I mentioned
in line with the statement that I
mentioned.
If it was good they would have preceded
us to it. Why? Because they are the
best.
If it was good they would have preceded
us to it. that with this and
they're the best because of the fact
that they preceded us to all act they
preceded us they were companions of the
messenger and they preceded them to all
there is nobody from the from the from
those who came later that are better
than them in action in belief in
understanding or in any of that you mean
so we cannot affirm this from any of
them the best generation
>> they usnot affirm it from the companion
we cannot confirm confirm it from the we
cannot confirm it from we cannot confirm
it from the
before.
But we're going to claim that somebody
who came from generations
that they have brought about something
that is better than any of them have
ever accepted.
Think about the
Just think about it. Think about what
you're suggesting. Think about what
you're allowing yourself to believe.
>> Is there a responsibility?
>> If you're allowing,
>> that's honestly
asking. Yeah, I hear you. But it will
probably be better and safer that you
don't respond.
>> Okay, then you let me. I'm telling I'm
saying to you the companions were the
best and you're going to respond to
that. You say
>> I'm I'm not denying that the fact that
the companions are the best. Everyone
agrees. In fact, if someone doesn't
agree that the companions are the best,
then there's an issue in his im.
>> We all agree to that, right?
>> What I don't agree is that just because
they didn't do something
and we did it, it invalidates this, you
know, it invalidates our action. And I I
was I was going to give you examples,
>> right?
>> No, no, we're we're not talking about
invalidating the action. If the action
is established, if it is established,
then uh yeah, we're not even speaking
about or looking into the issue of
invalidation.
But if the action is not established,
then it is invalid
regardless of how you feel about it.
>> Let me and this is not my statement.
have a question I wanted to ask. So the
point of the brother over here is he
trying to get the clarification or is he
trying to confirm here to teach maybe
you know the brothers before yesterday
he already discussed to
already tried his best to clarify. So we
have fear about the other people who are
around here. If he's teaching, maybe he
can have that conversation with you with
you
>> maybe to confirm what what he wants. But
for clarification, you know, you can we
already provided a lot and this is not
going to finish.
>> No,
>> because he's he's confirming he he wants
to teach you. And then I know that he's
not accepting whatever you give right
now.
>> So to protect our
>> I mean to be honest with you to be
honest with that statement follow up
what you just made there. I would agree
with his brother that it doesn't sound
to me that you're actually sincerely
looking for haya and guidance and
correctness. Sounds to me that you want
to prove yourself right
>> among these brothers here. I don't know
if you know them from previous.
>> So, so the criteria is
for almost 10 years. So whatever sounds
okay to you is, you know, definitely
okay. And whatever doesn't sound okay to
you is definitely not okay.
>> Since we've been speaking, have we been
talking about anything that sounds okay?
>> We not been speaking. We not been
speaking of and statement to the prophet
of Allah.
Was it just sounds you just made the
last
>> and the last statement? The last
statement was it based on hadith or not?
He br it up, right? He brought up the
the idea that you first of all known
that I mean, alhamdulillah, I I I'm
honored to have had the chance to speak
to you, right? But you maybe can ask
brother Naim and I don't know the other
brother, right? Who requested this
meeting?
>> Did I request this meeting?
>> Yes. And you know, I you know, out of
uh you know, out of respect, out of
>> obliged.
>> Yeah. I I obliged. Right. So I agreed to
be here and and and I told brother
because he was telling me
>> I told you
>> be very brief, right? And I
>> I told No, one second. I told you from
the beginning.
>> I told you. So don't make me feel like I
didn't tell you.
>> Okay.
>> I'm just letting you know.
>> I told you.
>> So what did he tell?
>> I'm just saying you know what I told
you.
>> Okay. So he told me that you you have to
be very brief and I told him that's my
intention.
>> No, I was telling you that you don't
come and ask your question.
>> That's it. That's it. I didn't I don't
approve of you. what was going on. I
just thought you got to come and ask a
question. That's it.
>> You didn't ask a question. You trying to
teach him. I'll be honest with you.
That's how it looks like.
>> This is Look, the thing is the thing is
this.
>> I think the brothers want good for you.
>> Okay.
>> The brothers would love to see I'm good
for them.
>> The brothers would love to see
>> and to leave alone following up chasing
up things that you have no evidence for.
>> Particularly those things that
>> I do have the evidence.
>> All right. The chance I'll give you the
evidence. particularly low. No, I'm
giving you
>> outside
ample ample opportunities. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. We're giving you
ample opportunity. I don't want you to
go away and say I was they didn't give
me the chance, right? Ample opportunity.
>> It's been it's been 51 minutes and he
gave you the open door.
>> We could have from from the very
beginning I asked you a simple question.
On what basis do you believe that you
can ask the dead? Right.
I said, but that is not a basis. No, no,
no, no, no. Our is based in evidence
first.
>> We don't we don't do something and then
say, well, there's nothing that says we
can't do it. That's not how we work.
Therefore, you must have evidence before
you act.
>> Have to on the basis of is inshallah
it's all right.
>> So I asked you a question from the very
beginning. What evidence do you believe
justifies the action that you carry out?
And you didn't answer me. So I know it
finish from there.
already
level I think it's better to you know to
stop it
brother
>> brother it seemed what it seems like
>> so before you say are you are you going
to allow me to respond to what
>> I'm not arguing with you the I've
already spent time but I'm just going to
say no
>> okay it's been 52 minutes
>> he gave you a open floor
You don't have to be a boy. Listen
without being allowed to respond just
based on based on what the you know has
come with you about the companions. It
seems like it seems like and I'm not
saying you are it seems like you're
trying to establish that your teachers
have more knowledge of the revelation
than the companions. So what I what I
adise what I what I what I what I advise
what I advise is that but he's coming
with you with the companions
understanding and you're saying and
you're saying that just because the
companions didn't do that doesn't mean
what what does it mean that's what it
seems like based on that statement but
what I advise you my brother is that
there are books there are books
the
these are people that you also that your
also agree with and the whole none none
None none of the claimments of disagree
with any of these messiah. Open these
books. Look at the we are people. You
know
when he said
[Music]
So then inshallah if we return to the
like the
>> should be suffic sufficient for that
there is nobody from the companion to be
that really should make you question
give you